uh you guys have any hopes for the new
year
i think 2020 has taught me to know my
place with expectations i think
i've thought about it i thought maybe i
could spend more than two hours outside
at a time
i don't know just go i i went on the
psychiat line today have you ever been
on the cycle
oh psycho sen oh and it's [ __ ] jr
line there is some sort of self-help
line
honestly honestly honestly i i need it
after going on it like
this morning because i go to class at
like 8 a.m so it's rush hour right
and the this it's [ __ ] insane so when
you go up to the platform
there's so many people waiting that like
they go to the next platform and start
like curling
off the side yeah and then it's just a
it is literally like as you saw in the
videos and they squish people on i
thought that was just like a
oh you've never been in that position
before well i've been on that now i have
every week
oh my god but but i never used to see it
as a tourist because i never used to go
at like the 8 am trains
it's not as bad in the evenings but
definitely in the morning it's horrible
and right now with kovacs avoid trains
between seven to eight thirty
it's one a.m i mean i still think it's
pretty bad in the evenings as well
but not as bad like you you can when
there's a question of
hmm how many people do i have to push
forward to get on this train and then
maybe just about like [ __ ] myself
like that's that's a little bit tricky
yesterday when i finished at around
6 00 p.m i feel like i feel like 6 p.m
is probably like the worst time to go
home
because i i remember it was it was the
same point where
you know like if you think about how to
get in the train and i thought the best
way to get in this train is to do a
[ __ ] run-up
so we tackle them [ __ ] rock me tackle
my way through
to get space and they just close with my
backpack
like touching the door yeah i i love
all these like just really you know
skinny like train
attendants just [ __ ] doing a full-on
rummy slice yeah
they treat it like a you know how
someone like get their car stuck in mud
like
get out push it put give it a push get
out come on come on steve give it a give
it a good push
and like i'm there and i'm like is there
an etiquette when the train is that
packed like because i'm crushing this
like these old ladies in this corner and
i can't do anything because i'm like
[ __ ] the force of zeus against this
door trying to like stop myself from but
when it's like
eight people's just like squishing i'm
like [ __ ] okay god and you do that right
on a daily
well at least once a week sometimes
twice a week i think that the reason why
they have to do that in the morning is
because they
don't want anyone to be late to work
yeah but all those trains
always are delayed that one well yeah
specifically exactly because there's two
people yeah so counterintuitive and then
when it gets delayed more people
are waiting for the train and it's just
it's an absolute mess it's a [ __ ] storm
i don't appreciate it sort that out
tokyo
and if i get if i if i got the rona you
know how the [ __ ] would you contact
trace
so who was in the train which 10 000 of
you also had it you know what i mean
like
it's scary it'd be easier to say who
wasn't on this yeah yeah
it's scary man yeah daunting i'm just
like what do i do if i get it [ __ ] all
right well [ __ ]
have you ever been on like uh that kind
of morning rush because
you know when yeah quite a bit and i
yeah i've done it and i learned my
lesson never to do it again because it's
not that bad up in the north right over
the north side
yeah yeah i'm sure if i started coughing
they'd all run away they'd make room
have you done that no no dude when i get
a sneeze now
i have like this zen moment of hold
hold on any form of coughing or anything
any noise bodily noise
like coughing goes okay but sneeze is
like it's it's [ __ ] scary because you
people
always look and like even when i'm
wearing a mask i'm just like
do i just sneeze or do i sneeze into my
hand or like elbow what
[Music]
you know what's the best way actually to
stop a sneeze there's a
there's a pressure point there's a
pressure point right here
on your top lip and if you push that
hard enough it actually do that in
public
okay
i've had so many times where i've wanted
to sneeze and publicly on
track there's a better technique rub
here right like that yeah and that's
better than going like that in it
i just screamed just go like that it
looks like you know you're just you're
just massaging your nose
like yeah i'm not saying to do this
but like it does work you can kind of
just like do like easily i usually do
with my pockets
just a magic curse on the track
[Music]
like that but i usually do it kind of
like with my thumb just very subtly like
that and it stops it every time i
thought it was [ __ ] too
because it was it's the one piece of
information that i saw in japanese tv
and i was like oh wow oh come on that's
no they they say stuff like yeah [ __ ]
your pants to get rid of rona
would start [ __ ] doing it they're an
absolute bunch of noises i thought
that's why i thought oh it's probably
[ __ ] but you know what i'll give it
a go and i tried it out once and i was
like
okay maybe that was a coincidence did it
twice i was like then
you know what i i want to see some
actual like knowledge i want to
subreddit for things of
it's probably [ __ ] but i'll give it
a go it's like you know what
i'm pretty sure there is something i
hope so your [ __ ] grandma's like
grandma's tails japanese tv
facts